um and then for us to lose you know it
just it sucks
um yeah it's not i mean
i don't really know what to say you know
i just uh i want to win and i want to
win the world series and that's the goal
so for us to lose
um yeah i mean it just sucks i mean i'm
not gonna question him
i mean he's a hell of a manager so i'm
not gonna question him
uh i'll voice my opinion and yeah i can
only look forward to you know the
off-season what i'm gonna accomplish to
stop student and get ready to
you know be the best me
um and the only thing you can do get
better and focus on what you know what i
can do to be better for next year
this year is over with uh congrats to
the dodgers you know they
they played better than us uh and they
earned it so
so good job to them but yeah we just
we came up short and that's pretty much
it there's nothing
you know i wish i could have been what
i'm so we're having trouble hearing you
go ahead i'm sorry oh yeah i'm just
saying that you know
it sucks and i want to be the guy that
stays out there as long as i can and you
know give this
team a chance to win every ball game and
it sucks you know
being pulled but yeah pretty much that's
it you feel like there's anything you
could have done to stay in the game
longer
that you could have done any better uh
no shot yeah that was
that was one of my better games i've
pitched in a long time honestly so
um the way i was controlling the zone
you know the way i was adjusting through
the uh seeing them you know i mean i
felt very comfortable out there
um the way that i scouted them the way
that i you know scouted myself
um with everything i mean i knew what
they were looking for i knew
when i was gonna switch it up i knew
when i was gonna adjust in the game
because i knew they were going to adjust
their game plan i mean
when it come to you know understanding
that team and what i needed to do to
succeed i was really locked in i knew
i mean yeah i felt i did everything i
could have done to stay
in that game and you know go as long as
i could have gone
um yeah so no i scouted them in myself
uh really really strongly so um
with everything you know i'm confident
in my ability and what i would have
continued to do
so um yeah i did everything i could to
be
the best me i could be today
juan trivia just kind of
with that is it frustrating they don't
let you get through a
third time to the lineup that's kind of
what cash said that uh
yeah i mean you know it's gonna be tough
man like i get it's a third time through
the lineup but
i mean what i think i'm gonna make the
adjustments i need to make as i see them
you know
a third time i think i don't know man i
just believe in me
i believe in my stuff i believe in you
know what i was doing i didn't walk
nobody
um they had two you know hits up the
middle you know
the slider the barns you know tip your
cap that was a bad pitch
um and he got a hit off that good job
but
for most of that game man i was
dominating every
you know every every outcome possible so
um and that lineup is so talented like
so
talented and yeah i don't know i'm just
i'm proud in the way that you know i
scouted them i scouted myself i'm just
proud of
everything i did to put the team in a
situation to win and
and i wanted to keep going man i felt i
felt so confident
you know how i adjusted through seeing
him a second time and what i was going
to be able to do a third time like
man i just i believed a lot in myself
and what i did to you know
hopefully see him a third time through
and the fourth time if needed i mean i
wanted to go that whole game that was my
that was everything i wanted to do was
just you know burn the tank and
see how far i could go
were you surprised i mean was there any
conversation there did you continue
no no no there was no convo he just came
out and
you know that was it he said hell of a
job and
yeah but i don't know when you when you
see the outcome it sucks because we
ended up losing so
the end of the day like i want to be the
guy that's out there win or lose like i
wanted to be
like i lost the game or you know i won
the game by
you know putting a performance that
could have helped the team win win or
lose so
i mean you could say i'm being selfish
but i just felt with how i felt today
like you got i just want to ride
part of the reason why you guys made it
to the world series was because of the
unique
decision making of cash and of the front
office and as a competitor are you
able to to see and understand why he
made that decision at the time he did
or with what your stuff was like tonight
can you not comprehend why that decision
was made
um i mean i said it to mark's question i
mean
cash is a hell of a manager we can't
take that away from him
i mean if nick gets out of the gym like
he usually does and
our bullpen holds it down like they
usually do no one's talking about it
so at the end of the day i see both
sides
but i mean just me and the way that you
know i felt
that game and what he was able to see
during that game i just
i don't want to be taken out of that
game i mean i don't like being taken out
of any game honestly
and for the most part you know me and
cash i'm gonna i'm gonna side with him
because i know how good of a manager he
is
and you know it's just tough it's tough
because like i felt so good i felt like
i did everything i could possibly do to
succeed against
that dodger lineup which is really hard
to do because of how talented they are
so i don't know man i for me i just i
want to be the guy that goes out there
and if
if they beat me they beat me but if i
beat them i beat them
um and that was kind of just how i was
looking at it like i wanted to
i wanted to burn out like i wanted to be
the one that wanted lost that game
so um it's just tough man and
i don't know like how to word it or say
like
cash is usually right so for you guys
that are gonna write
bad stories on the decision like he's
usually right
um and yeah man it just it sucks i mean
i'm a competitor i want to be the best
in the world so
it sucks for me on that end and you know
it's just there's no real way to angle
this to make a
what he should have done and shouldn't
have done like he's usually right when
he takes people out so
there's no you know pointing the fingers
or anything like that it's just
i'm a competitor he's a competitor
everyone on this team is a competitor so
he did what he thought was gonna be the
best move and you know they capitalized
on it and
that's that time for a couple more go to
stephanie
like do you think it's harder to lost
this way than it would have been if you
had gone out there and like
if you'd left you out you'd give up or
whatever and lost that way
oh well i'm gonna just say i'm not gonna
go out there to give up a home run and
lose that way that's just
that's not happening um the way like my
mind works
i don't see like them doing that i see
you know me succeeding and me
you know sticking to a game plan
adjusting learning and growing and
that's that's how i've always looked at
it so
i don't look at it like if i stayed out
there they would have hit a home run i
look at it
if i stayed out there like we're going
to win because there's i don't really
put negative into my mind or like they
can hit a home run and get hits like i
always look at what i can do and
you know i look at the best version of
myself and that's kind of how i've
always done it but
yeah i don't know i just want to be the
guy that's out there and if if i lose
like i do
but i just you know i just don't see it
and i never will see it because i always
look at a positive angle of what i'm
going to be able to accomplish
um but that's i don't know it's just how
i work i work
that way of always you know believing in
myself and knowing that
i'm the best option
last question from jesse rogers
like a lot of players around the league
tweeted about computers and analytics
running things when you were pulled
is that sort of the ultimate sign of
baseball today that you know this
sort of move is it's not uncommon let's
put it that way yeah it's definitely not
uncommon
um i don't know man it's just the
hardest thing for me is i was rolling
i was in a groove um you know i just
really felt
dominant and i felt like i had them
guessing and
you know i just it's just tough for me
man it's going to be tough for me for a
while to like
accept that and accept you know losing
the world series
it's a lot man i don't really know how
to look at it it's just it sucks
and whatever way you look at it we lost
so if i would have stayed out there and
we like we lost so
losing sucks but the only thing i can
say that i hope before like
i wrap this up um i just hope you know
the guys understand like
we should not be okay with taking second
or losing like we should not be okay
with that we gotta find a way to be
better for next year
coming to spring hungry um getting this
far and losing should be the worst
feeling in the world so
um for the guys in the clubhouse i just
hope you know
they understand rest a couple weeks if
that's what they're gonna do and then
get ready for like a championship season
next year we got to win it all
this losing stuff isn't fun and when
when you get
this kind of opportunity and you know
you lose to a great team
every team's great in the playoffs but
when you lose to a team it really does
suck so i just hope the guys in our
clubhouse
get ready for next year and you know we
come out to win this thing next year and
hopefully
this can fuel us but outside of that
we had a good year um we had a lot of
good memories a lot of things that you
know propel us in the right direction
so that's that from mine but
hope you guys have a good off season you
all stay healthy with this whole covet
and
um yeah congratulations to the dodgers
all right thank you everyone
get good
we're gonna get started with questions
for kevin kiermeier
we'll take the first question from mark
topkin
kevin i guess just knowing how invested
you are in this team and its success can
you kind of just describe the feeling of
how this ended and
losing tonight um
you know we uh we wanted to win this
obviously
came in here feel feeling really good
about ourselves but um you know that
now that's over with it it's just um
i don't know i'm not i'm not sad i'm not
disappointed
um i'm so proud of of
everyone in our whole organization for
what we accomplished this year
um you know came up a little bit short
of what our
goal was and that was to be out there
celebrating right now hosting that
trophy up but
um dodgers played they played better
than us
they um they did and and
you know four games of two it is what it
is and and they they did a great job
they they pitch they hit they they score
in many different ways and
uh you know we got beat
fair and square and uh
but you know talking about our group uh
man there was there were so many things
to be so proud of excited for
all the great moments that we are part
of this year
uh i i said a little something to the
guys after the game and
i said you know what we we sat here we
won the division
we came to play each and every day we
handled business against the blue jays
in the playoffs beat a very
good yankees team and and was able to
experience that great game five moment
with bros and then
you know the astro series we made it
very interesting and and found a way to
win at the most crucial time and
in here um being able to experience this
and
and be in this moment knowing that uh we
deserve to be here
uh you know meant the world to all of us
and obviously once again we would love
to win it but um
you know it just wasn't our time and but
to experience what we did
game four with brett phillips and watch
randy orazarena this whole time be the
best player on the planet there there
was a lot of really good things to be
proud of
and um i know i'm rambling now but i'm
so proud to be
a part of this group and this
organization and um
you know just a pure joy from from the
get-go given with all the
protocols and what we're up against
means the world uh you know to go to
battle with these guys each every day so
i'm at peace i really am i'm you know
obviously would have loved to win this
but um
in hindsight there's a lot to be proud
of life is good
and kevin you've seen kevin cash make
decisions throughout the season many of
them have worked out what was your
reaction to that move tonight
uh i'm not the manager i
i don't i don't make um decisions i
you know asking for my opinion though i
think it was it was blake's game
he was dominating um i don't
really care what the numbers say third
time through the order whatever he
there wasn't many guys making contact in
general and
and no hard contact whatsoever
and uh you know i think
we all wanted to see him go in there but
our are staying there
but it's uh you know cash and
everyone had they've been great this
whole year
uh with making decisions and you know it
didn't work out for us right there but
you know with blake's pitch count and
how dominant he was i think
all of us well no i can't even say that
i i wanted to see him stay in because uh
you know he's had the early hook last
couple times out there and
i was hoping they'd give him that final
nod but uh you know being up one nothing
that probably didn't
help our chances if we had three three
or four run lead
things would have been different but you
know the situation was we were up one
nothing and
and uh they wanted to go to the bullpen
right there but i thought blake was
dominant from first pitch to the last
and
you know coulda woulda shoulda who knows
what would have happened but
um you know he threw the ball great that
might have been the best i've seen him
it was incredible
juan tribia hey kevin
on that note said that maybe that's what
they needed to kind of see a pitching
change
on your side is that anything did that
deflate
yeah it did um you know even though
it was 1-0 we 1-0 lead right there
uh you know we've with the way blake was
throwing
um we thought that he could have got
through
two or three more innings potentially
given what his pitch count was and you
know
decisions from that point on but um
[Music]
yeah you know of course uh you know
baseball works in mysterious ways and
then
mookie hits a double right there and and
they got some momentum on their side
than the wild pitch and
then uh seeger's rbi ground out um you
know everything unfolded pretty quickly
but you know it was unfortunate to see
but we've we've uh had a certain formula
throughout the whole year and
you know we won a lot of ball games like
that it just it didn't work in our favor
tonight
and uh you know it's easy to sit here
and um
like i said say coulda woulda shoulda
but
we went with uh you know with our gut
and it just didn't work out for us
but how long do you think you'll wrestle
with that
idea of wondering what would have
happened if blake had stayed in there
you know what to be honest not even
giving you a politically
correct answer or anything um it's done
and over with
uh is easy it is it as it is to sit here
and
and have those conversations with with
certain people um
[Music]
it does us it does us no good right now
because they're out there
celebrating right now and you know our
season came to an end
um you know runners-up of this whole
thing
so it's uh
you know it does it's no good to sit
here and um
[Music]
you know try to figure out what would
have happened
if blake would have stayed in um and
it's a very fair question i'll say that
but
once again we made the decisions that we
did and and went with
you know certain personnel and it just
didn't work out in our favor and i
i think um you know a lot of people will
sit here and go back uh and you know
there's probably a lot of other people
who want to answer that question for you
but once again
we have a certain formula for how we try
to win ball games and
it just didn't work out for us tonight
life goes on
a lot to be proud of in our clubhouse
oh hey kevin yeah you talk about the
formula and such is that just
kind of part of the i guess the deal or
the bargain of playing for the raise in
that you
you accept the good outcomes and then
you have to kind of i guess
accept it when maybe something that goes
against the real traditional baseball
book doesn't go your way
i mean you just sort of on balance
live with it when it doesn't go go your
way even if you felt a guy like blake
was dealing
yeah you win as a team you lose as a
team um
and you and you go from there but
um you know it's
when you win those ball games no one
really raises concern or no one really
talks about a whole lot and and you know
it worked out for you then you move on
but whenever things don't work out for
you that's when
uh you know everyone wants to magnify
things and and
you know talk about and like i said it's
very fair trust me i
i totally understand that but
once again we we've been uh we know how
everything works uh you know analytics
is
is a huge part of our success and
sometimes it can bite you in the butt
um sometimes a human element of the game
can bite you in the butt when you go
with your gut things always don't work
out for you
that's baseball that's what makes this
game so great there's a lot of
gambles you take throughout the course
of a game
that a lot of people don't realize and
it's easy to sit here and be manager
from your couch or the living room
wherever but
uh you know there's a lot of work that
goes into this each and every day before
each and every game and
like i said when things don't work out
for you that's when you want to sit here
and talk about it rightfully so but uh
once again we win as a team we lose as a
team
take a final question from stephanie
hey kevin uh sorry that we do this i'm
sorry for
adding to it uh but is
and maybe you can answer this do you
think it's is it harder to lose
like this when there are so many should
have as opposed to like if your guy
stays out there and
yeah i said i mean um
i thought it was blake's game to lose if
that makes
any sense um that's my opinion
i just i was i had a great seat in
center field and and watching how he was
just striking out
everybody and his slider curveball
heater changeup had everything going
and you know his pitch count had to be
around
73 or 74 i remember looking up and
seeing that so
um yeah i mean it's
it was an unfortunate way to to see it
end i mean
it was no doubt about it but
um once again you know kevin cash our
front office everyone you know they put
together a certain game plan and they've
been right
time and time again and you know if we
would have scored more runs
um and had you know better at bats and
and try to generate more offense to give
blake a little bit more breathing room
you know he would have stayed in there
so
um you know we we did what he we did and
it didn't work out i mean plain and
simple
there's uh yeah not much more to it than
that
but
you know life goes on and uh you know
once again so proud of this group
we accomplished a ton a lot to be proud
of and uh you know guys should go into
the off season with their heads
held high thank you
all right that's all the time we have
for kk thanks very much
you
you
yes
we're gonna get started with nick
anderson we'll take the first question
from mark
obviously you haven't had the results as
much recently as you had
earlier and during the season are you
are you healthy and what do you think
the difference has been if you are
yeah you know um it's been 2020 it's
been crazy
um and really kind of went out there and
left it online every game and
just kind of came up short i guess you
know not a lot of gas in the tank
and then tonight you didn't get hit hard
obviously you think the
bits hit was the key moment there
i don't know sure yeah
like yeah i mean got a double he got on
base
so um
i don't really got much to say
is it all for you mark yeah it's fine
john ramona
nick were you expecting uh kevin paul
bank at that point in the game can you
say that again
were you expecting kevin come out of the
darkness
um yeah i mean i got a call we got a
call in the bullpen for me to start
warming up
so yeah
justin grant
nick were you told pregame at all about
what the plan could be about third time
through the order that
that mookie would be your guy uh no it
wasn't anything like that
um just the way that the playoffs have
been obviously
you know it could could be in the fourth
fifth whatever um
whatever that kind of rolls around to be
so there there was no there was no
set set time or anything just kind of
the way the game was going or
or whatever
one i think kind of an angle's life were
you surprised
when the call was made kind of based
upon what you were seeing
what blake was doing on the mount at
that time um you know that the the way
cash manages and
does his thing i mean it got us here so
um
i don't really i don't really put too
much thought into that
just try to be trying to be as ready as
possible when my name gets called and
you know obviously i'll tell you i'll
take heat for
for not not holding up holding up my end
on uh
on this kind of playoff stretch but um
you know it wasn't it wasn't anything to
do with effort
anything i was going out there kind of
just letting it on
laying it on the line every time and uh
just uh
fell a little short but it uh i don't
wanna i don't wanna turn the page too
quickly but
come in ready next year
stephanie epstein
i'm sorry i that was me sure
tyler kepner go ahead and nick you've
been so
great for the raise um you know really
since you got here
lately have you have you just been tired
i mean has the workload this month
caught up to you or did you feel as
strong now as you do
when you're at your best
uh i mean i def definitely know um
you know workload 2020 season i don't
the the whole the whole thing
is is just crazy uh honestly um
during quarantine not having a normal
routine lifting
to the season you know everything's just
uh
it's it's been crazy so um yeah you know
it's i didn't feel as good as i would
have liked to but
you know it uh it's a big leagues like
you're not going to go out and feel good
every time so i was going out there and
you know i was still still confident
still you know it wasn't the situation
um i wasn't being in the world series
series or
or anything like that um just uh
yeah kind of kind of trying to find my
stuff a little bit and
and not a lot of gas you know velo was
down
um so it was going out there and trying
to give her everything i got and
didn't work out and that's part of what
relievers pride themselves on right
is is whatever you're feeling telling
the manager you're ready to go
and give it the best you've got did you
tell um
you know stan or or or kyle or anybody
like
you know maybe you were you maybe you
were running out of gas a little bit
um i i guess i didn't really i didn't
really say anything
um because to me it's i don't know
i don't want to say it's not important
because whether you're kind of running
out of gas or not you know